a répondu aux inquiétudes d'une bonne
partie des britanniques
il n'est pas le seul le confinement est
donc prolongé jusqu'au 1er juin
elle décide non cyclique date à laquelle
il espère pouvoir rouvrir
progressivement magasins et écoles
primaires aux états unis la maladie
semble s'en prend de manière inusitée
aux enfants après le décès de deux
jeunes enfants et jeunes adolescents de
possibles complications liées à la coved
19 l'état de new york enquêtent sur 85
autres cas de jeunes atteints de
diverses complications pulmonaires ou
autre même la maison blanche n'est pas à
l'abri du coronavirus trois membres du
groupe de travail sur la coved 19 dont
le scientifique en chef anthony facci
ont été mises en quarantaine après être
entré en contact avec une personne
déclarée positive gros championship
tournoi en corée du sud séoul ordonne la
fermeture temporaire de ses bars et de
ses clubs
une cinquantaine de nouveaux cas
d'infection ont été rattachées à un
jeune homme de 29 ans qui aurait
fréquenté un quartier branché de la
ville
en allemagne pas si vite les
réjouissances après un assouplissement
des restrictions nationales
voilà que de nouveaux cas d'infections
font leur apparition
[Musique]
l'arpp pour certains être un bon ou en
ces temps de pandémie
c'est la mission que s'est donnée ce
pianiste de sao paulo au beau milieu
d'une autoroute en ce jour de la fête
des mères
ici gabriel proulx radio canada montréal